Just a few last remarks.
Last day we were intensively
looking at the structure and
properties of oxide glasses,
and I just have a few remarks left
to make about that and then we will
move onto kinetics today.
Just a reminder, we saw that oxide
glasses typically consist of three
types of components,
primarily network formers.
These are covalent oxides that form
oxygen bridges between
the metal species.
And we can tailor the nature of the
network by adding so-called
modifiers which are ionic oxides,
and they donate oxide ions. The
oxide ions go into the network and
they break the oxygen bonds in a
process we call scission.
And then lastly in certain glasses
we add a compound of a type called
an intermediate.
And these are actually network
formers, but they form a different
number of bonds than
the parent network.
Typically a larger number of bonds.
And, in doing so, they create some
free volume which enhances certain
properties, sometimes the mechanical
properties, sometimes the thermal
properties. Specifically,
thermal shock resistance is enhanced
by the addition of network formers.
And, at the end of the lecture, we
had started talking about
strengthening mechanisms.
And the way to strengthen oxide
glasses --
Remember, oxide glasses are not too
bad in compression but are very weak
in tension. And the way to
strengthen them is to pre-stress
compressively so that the effective
yield stress becomes then the sum of
the natural yield stress of the
material, plus the compressive
stress that you have added to the
material. And you don't have to
necessarily do this through the
entire material.
Typically, we simply pre-stress the
surface. Because,
let's face it, if something is going
to fail, it is going to fail through
the application of force causing the
crack at the free surface.
If we can prevent the crack from
forming at the free surface this can,
in many instances,
preserve the integrity of the object.
We saw the first way of improving
the strength of an oxide glass
called tempering.
And that exploits differential
cooling so that if you look on this
trace here, volume versus
temperature, we know that if we have
surface cooling at a high rate,
we will have a higher excess volume
than if we have cooling in the bulk
of the glass at a lower rate.
And that leads to a differential in
volume which ultimately has a
compressive stress on the surface.
There is another way to achieve the
same goal, that is compressive
stress on the surface,
and that involves a chemical
treatment. And,
in particular, what we can do is
take the glass --
And I am going to give a
representative composition here.
Let's say we have a glass that
consists of, we will have a network
former, silica,
and a network modifier will be soda,
sodium oxide, and we will throw in
an intermediate,
alumina. This is a sodium
aluminosilicate glass.
Former. Modifier. Intermediate.
And we know that the sodium ions
are present. The oxide ions have
gone into the network and have
resulted in the formation of
terminal oxygens here.
The sodiums are still free as sodium
ions. Let's take a look at the
sodium ions at the surface of the
glass. Some of the surface sites
are going to be occupied by sodium
ions. What we can do is immerse
this glass into a molten salt at
elevated temperature.
Typically, let's look at something
like potassium chloride.
This melts at 775 centigrade,
so this might be sitting at 800
degrees C.
And, as a molten salt,
it consists of potassium cations and
chloride anions.
Take a look at this interface here.
On the left I have a high
concentration of sodium but no
sodium in the molten salt.
In the molten salt, I have a high
concentration of potassium but no
potassium in the glass.
By virtue of the concentration
gradient, potassium will want to
enter the lattice and displace some
of the sodium and some of the sodium
will want to leave to enter the salt.
Ions are soluble in
an ionic medium.
What happens if a potassium ion
enters the glass and occupies a site
previously held by sodium?
Well, we know that the radius of
the potassium ion is substantially
larger than the radius of the sodium
ion. If potassium enters the glass,
it is going to be a force fit. This
means force fit.
And it is going to lead to the
generation of compressive stress.
And this is not too different from
what happens when you put carbon
into iron. The carbon is larger
than the interstitial site in iron.
This treatment is called ion
exchange. By ion exchange,
which is a chemical treatment,
we can also strengthen the glass and
thereby make it a little
more robust for use.
I think that is a good place to stop
the treatment of glasses,
and we may return a little bit later
in the semester.
What I want to do now is start a
new unit. And the unit I want to
talk about today is a unit that
would be called,
from the domain of physical
chemistry, I want to talk about
chemical kinetics.
And chemical kinetics is the study
of reaction rates and mechanisms.
And this is very important for a
number of reasons.
For that we discuss it in 3.
91. Let's talk about three reasons
that come to mind.
First of all, productivity.
If we go into an industrial setting
and we want to improve throughput or
yield, we need to understand the
rates and mechanisms of reactions.
This is linked to competitiveness,
it is linked to resource utilization,
efficient use of materials and
energy if we know how to process
things effectively.
The second thing is environment.
A number of you have come to me
after class and,
on different occasions,
spoken of your interests in
environmental matters.
Well, one of the simplest things
one can do to minimize adverse
environmental impact of chemical
processes is to be efficient.
Understanding how reactions proceed
is critical in minimizing the
adverse environmental impact.
Productivity issues. Secondly,
environmental issues. And, thirdly,
societal issues ultimately. You are
here at MIT. You want to get an
analytical education and you want to
go out and do something
in the world.
And one of the things that can
happen, if you understand your
chemistry and understand the
kinetics, is you can keep a plant
operative, you can keep people
working. There are societal
implications for failure to
understand kinetics.
When a process becomes obsolete,
you go out of business and people go
out of work. For these,
and many other reasons, we want to
study kinetics.
And kinetics takes place over a
very wide range.
That is why I played the song about
time.
That is what this is about.
It is about time. We have at the
one extreme very slow chemical
processes, and at the other extreme
very fast chemical processes.
Slow, we have things that take
place along geological or even
cosmic time scales.
A very, very slow processes.
And, on the other extreme, we have
such things as explosions.
And explosions are not necessarily
destructive. For example,
in the airbag that operates in an
automobile, it operates thanks to
the fast kinetics of a
glass solid reaction.
There is no pump that can inflate an
airbag at an acceptably high rate to
do you any good in an automobile
crash. What happens here is the
kinetics of a reaction between two
solids. What we have is basically
solid plus solid goes to gas.
And, as you know, the volume of a
gas is thousands of times
the volume of a solid.
And, in particular,
it is the reaction of sodium azide
with potassium nitrate.
And one of the products is nitrogen
gas in huge quantities.
You have your accelerometer which
decides that you are decelerating at
a rate that is alarmingly high.
It probably not a healthy occasion.
A tiny electric current flows
through a wire which acts as the
trigger for this reaction.
Once the reaction goes, you can
inflate the airbag in a
matter of milliseconds.
What we want to do is understand
some of the basics of chemical
kinetics. We are going to look at a
general reaction and understand how,
first of all, to characterize
chemical reactions.
Let's characterize the rate of a
chemical reaction.
I am going to write a.
Little a is stoichiometry and big A
is some chemical identity.
A moles of A plus b moles of B
react to form little c moles of C
plus little d moles of C.
That is sort of a prototypical
reaction. And kinetics accounts for
the rate of conversion.
That is what we want to know.
How quickly are we consuming our
reactants?
How quickly are we generating our
products? That is what we are
interested in understanding.
We have, first of all, a simple
thing. We have conservation of mass
operating, which we have seen from
the early part of 3.
91, that the rate of consumption of
all of the reactants must equal the
rate of production of
all of the products.
There are no sources or sinks.
We have no wormholes here.
Everything that goes into the plant
has to come out of the plant in some
other way. And specifically we can
even get into looking at the rate of
disappearance of a single reactant.
For example, the stoichiometry
would dictate that the rate at which
I consume a, this is one over a,
this is the pre-multiplier, times
the change in the concentration.
I apologize for the multiple fonts
here.
In this case, little c represents
the stoichiometry.
In this case, this represents
concentration of A.
The rate of change of concentration
of A, the rate of its disappearance.
When it is normalized for mole
number would be the same as the rate
of appearance of D,
so d by dt of the concentration of D.
We have these individual
relationships.
This is simply conservation of mass.
We have that. And now comes the
interesting point of kinetic theory.
What kinetic theory says is that
there is a relationship between the
instant rate of consumption of a
product and its concentration.
In other words, we essentially say
that concentration of a reactant is
the driving force for reaction.
Let's say in terms of a word
equation, the rate of change of
concentration of any species,
this is the concentration of some
species i, is proportional to the
instant concentration.
And that makes sense. If you have
a lot of a substance,
it is going to have a high chemical
potential to react.
If you have a dilute concentration
of a substance,
it will have a weak propensity to
react. But it is not a linear
relationship. It is some
power-based relationship.
We have to say raised to some power.
Conceptually,
that is what is going on.
Now we can write this in
mathematical formulation.
Let's say we are looking at the
rate of consumption,
so that is d by dt of some
concentration of species i.
I am going to say it is proportional
to the concentration of species i,
it is raised to some power, and this
n is now the order of reaction.
You have seen n used so many times
in 3.091. It was a quantum number
in the Bohr model.
It was an index of refraction.
It was in the Born repulsion.
Today it is functioning as the order
of reactions. N is a very
talented variable.
It is not typecast in a simple role
is what I am saying.
Now, how do I take a
proportionality and turn it into an
equality? I put in a constant of
proportionality.
And that constant of
proportionality is called the
specific chemical rate constant.
And these have to be determined by
experiment. You cannot look at the
stoichiometry of a reaction and
infer what the order of reaction is.
These must be determined by
experiment.
Let's look at that first equation
and write it in its most general
form. What you could say is that
the rate of change of concentration
of species A goes as some constant
times the concentration of species A
to some arbitrary power alpha,
but it may be influenced by some
other concentration.
To be most general, we say
concentration of species B raised to
some power times the concentration
of species C raised to some power.
You might say,
well, how can the concentration of
species C have any influence on the
rate of consumption of species A?
Well, what if species C acts in
some way as an inhibitor to the
reaction? As the concentration of
the product goes up,
it could actually choke off the
reaction. To be general,
we will put all four in here.
And we will call these alpha,
beta, gamma and delta all partial
orders of reaction.
To be determined experimentally.
And, by the way, they do not have
to be integers.
They are not necessarily integer.
You can have something that is
half-order or one third-order
reaction, not necessarily integer
values. Let's look at one.
Here is a simple reaction.
Unfortunately,
it is a little bit toxic.
This is carbon monoxide plus
chloride which will react
to generate phosgene.
COCl2 is phosgene.
I have worked with this stuff in my
research. Actually,
it has a fantastic ability to
desiccate material.
If you have a solid that has a
parts per million residual water,
if you expose it to phosgene,
phosgene will attack the water,
generating carbon dioxide and HCl.
It is very good. Unfortunately, it
was also used in gas warfare during
World War I. It is now banned by
international treaty.
On the basis of experimental
evidence, we know that the rate of
consumption of carbon monoxide in
this reaction is related to the
concentration of carbon monoxide
linearly and the concentration of
chlorine to the power of
three-halves based on experiment.
We would say that this reaction is
first-order in carbon monoxide.
Because there is a linear
relationship between the rate of
consumption of carbon monoxide and
the concentration.
This is C to the power one,
but we don't write the one. It is
of order 1.5 in chlorine.
Or, we could say wholly or entirely
of order 2.5. That gives you a
sense of how the rate of
disappearance of one constituent can
depend on not just its own
concentration but other
concentrations.
Clearly, if we are trying to build a
plant to make phosgene,
we now have a quantitative measure
of how to improve the rate of
throughput. Suppose somebody says
we would like to build a plant that
produces so many tons per year,
well, you know what your limitations
are in terms of concentration so you
can figure out what you would have
to do in a quantitative
predictive manner.
Well, there is another way we can
improve the yield.
What is another way to improve
yield in a reaction?
Instead of increasing concentration,
we can increase temperature.
We know that materials tend to
react more quickly with one another
at elevated temperature.
Where is the elevated temperature
going to fit into this equation?
I don't see any temperature term.
Temperature must be buried in the
rate constant.
And that is where we are going to
go. We are going to look inside the
rate constant.
We will increase yield by increasing
temperature. And that was known for
many, many years,
but it was finally the Swedish
chemist Arrhenius who in 1889
announced the relationship that
bears his name.
What he found was that the
relationship between the specific
rate constant and temperature was
exponential through an
equation of this form.
Exponential of the ratio of some
energy, which he termed the
activation energy,
divided by the product of the
Boltzmann constant and temperature
and a pre-exponential factor which
we write as A in honor of Arrhenius.
Or, another way you can write it in
this manner, A e to the minus Ea
over k Boltzmann T.
So there is the relationship.
And another way of showing it is to
put it on a semi log plot.
If you plot the natural logarithm of
the rate constant as a function of
the reciprocal of the absolute
temperature, you will find that,
according to this equation, you
should get a straight line.
One over T is increasing from left
to right so high temperature is on
the left side,
and this should be linear with a
slope of minus Ea,
which is the activation energy,
divided by the Boltzmann constant.
And just to give you a sense of
order of magnitude,
the activation energy for typical
chemical reactions is on the order
of about one electron volt,
which is on the order of about 100
kilojoules per mole.
If you take this and choose an
arbitrary rate for room temperature,
plug in the value of 100 kilojoules
per mole, what you can show yourself
is that with this activation energy
you double the rate for every ten
degrees rise above room temperature.
Obviously this breaks down for large
excursions in temperature.
But in the vicinity of room
temperature, if you have an
activation energy,
you typically have about a one
electron volt,
you can expect to double for every
ten degrees. What is the physical
meaning of activation energy?
Well, I thought I would try to show
it to you in terms of
a mechanical analog.
What I am going to do here is show
you what we can say is going to be,
say, a loudspeaker. What I have
done by putting the x on the
loudspeaker at the intersection of
the x is we will say that that is
the center of mass of the
loudspeaker. The loudspeaker is now
in a gravitational field.
And we can argue that I could
represent this as a point of zero
dimension at this height
off the table.
Now, clearly, if I lay this on its
side, the point has fallen.
It is now at a lower gravitational
potential. Really,
if the box had its way,
the box would prefer to lie on its
side. How come the box doesn't just
fall on its side?
Why doesn't the box just lie on its
side? See, it is a decrease in
energy when I do that.
Did you see the photon?
It is absorbed. Now look at it go.
Why doesn't the box fall on its
side?
Well, this is a box at zero Kelvin.
Now let's put the box at room
temperature. What is happening at
room temperature?
Well, the box is doing this at room
temperature. Even so,
the box won't fall on its side.
Why? Because, in order for the box
in three space to go from the
vertical upright locked position to
the supine position,
what must the box do?
The box must first rise up on one
corner. And only when it rises up
on one corner and gets to this cusp
does it have the ability
to fall freely.
What we are looking at,
in terms of gravitational potential,
is activation. I can now give you
the same thing.
I could plot this as extent of
reaction on the abscissa and some
energy relative to gravitational
potential on the ordinate,
and I have three positions here.
I have the box in the vertical
position, I have the box in the
horizontal position and,
clearly, there is a decrease in
energy.
This change is the delta E of the
reaction, but the box cannot get to
the right position from the left
position without first rising up on
its side. It must,
at some point, rise up on its side.
And when it rises up on its side
its center of mass has risen,
and this energy is the activation
energy.
That is the mechanical analog.
The delta E reaction, this is the
driving force for the reaction in
the first place.
And Ea, in fact,
is the gatekeeper.
It determines the rate of reaction
because, on the basis of Ea,
Ea mediates the rate constant.
So, all other things being equal,
temperature gives you the rate
constant through Ea.
And now we will recall the other
temperature effect.
You say, gee, how does any of this
stuff happen? You know that room
temperature energy is typically on
the order of about one-fortieth of
an electron volt,
and I just told you that chemical
reactions have activation energies
on the order of one electron volt.
According to that, we would have to
be up at thousands of degrees
centigrade in order to promote any
chemical reactions.
How do we get chemical reactions at
200, 300 degrees centigrade?
What we have going on is the
distribution of energies.
And I will go back to that plot we
saw earlier. Here is T1.
Here is the average energy at T1.
And out here is one electron volt,
or whatever it happens to be, the
activation energy.
And so only the fraction of the
population that has greater than the
activation energy is able to
participate in the reaction.
And we have seen before the measure
of the area under this curve from Ea
out to infinity is given by the
relationship Ea,
k Boltzmann T, exponential of which.
And so it was Boltzmann who first
gave us this understanding,
then Maxwell gave us the
distribution and away we go.
What happens by changing
temperature, we have seen before.
When we change temperature,
the curve moves ever so slightly so
that the average energy at T2,
where T2 is greater than T1, moves a
little bit. But what happens up
here is the area under the curve
between Ea and infinity goes up by
large leaps and bounds.
And that is how, by modest
increases in temperature,
we are able to get substantial
increases in the rate of reaction.
Now let's look at some specific
reactions of various common orders.
I am going to look at first-order
which is the most common,
and then I am going to look at
second-order. Let's look at
first-order reactions.
Here is an example. The example is
N2O5 decomposes to give us NO2 plus
O2. There is the stoichiometry of
the reaction, but on the basis of
measurements in the laboratory we
can write that the rate of
consumption of N2O5 --
The square brackets denote
concentration.
It is found to be linear in
concentration of N2O5,
or N2O5 raised to the first power.
This we say is a first-order
reaction. And I am getting tired of
writing N2O5 bracket,
bracket, so I am just going to write
c. C represents all of this.
I am compressing the font. I am
going to rewrite this equation as
minus dc by dt equals
kc. **-dc/dt = kc**
That is a first-order reaction.
Why? Because this is a one. That
is why it is first-order.
It is linearly dependent.
The rate of change you see is
linearly dependent on concentration.
I do a little bit of calculus here.
I can invert this,
and I can then write minus dc over c
equals k dt. And what we are going
to is integrate this thing out so
that we can get the
timeline on this.
And so I can put an integration sign
here. K is independent.
We can do that. And I am going to
start at time zero where I have some
initial concentration and go to some
arbitrary concentration c and
arbitrary time t.
What I am going to look at is this.
This is some initial concentration
versus time. We know all of these
things are going to attenuate.
I want to know what this curve
really, really looks like.
And I know some of you are sitting
there wincing saying that because
your math professors have told you
that you cannot make the limits of
an integral the same as the value of
the integrand.
I don't want to go to math jail,
so we will put little tildes over
this so that all the math weenies
are happy here.
But what I could do to really make
it pedantic is - let's not do that.
Let's use a carrier variable. I
will make this s,
which now you don't know what I am
talking about, and I
will make this c.
And that is mathematically beautiful.
It does not explain what we are
talking about so I am going to go
back and put the c with a little
tilde over it so everybody now is
happy. This is t with a little
tilde. And if we integrate this
thing out what do we get?
We get that the natural log of c
goes as the natural log of the
initial concentration c naught minus
kt. What I am talking about is the
way that I can determine what the
order of reaction is is to look at
the functional shape of this.
In other words,
whether it is first-order,
second-order or 2.5-order, they all
look like this,
the curves. What I really need to
do is, what the I is capable of
doing is detecting something simple
like straight line.
If I am cleaver about it,
if I take instead of c versus t,
if instead I map this into
functional.
I map c into some function of c and
I map t into some function of t,
that is embedded in the physical
chemistry of the process so that f
of c should be a linear function of
g of t, whether it is this or
whether it this.
Then I can inspect and say that
looks linear. Therefore,
the assumptions that underlie those
functions must be what is going on.
And that is the way we determine
order of reaction.
One other reaction I want to give
you, even though it
is not chemistry.
I still want you to understand,
this falls under the rubric of
general culture,
that radioactive decay obeys
first-order kinetics.
Let's just take note of that.
Radioactive decay is first-order.
For example, here is a reaction.
U-238 can decompose to give
thorium-234 plus helium.
And if we plot concentration of
uranium as a function of time,
starting with some initial value c
naught, we will just have this
attenuation. But if we map it into
the natural log of c versus time,
we will get a straight line, and the
slope here will give us minus k.
And we know that this is n equals
one because, if you see a plot of
natural log of concentration as a
function of temperature,
if it is a straight line,
bingo, that tells you that this must
be first-order and the slope of that
line is minus k.
Now, it turns out that people that
work in radioactive decay do not
like to express the rate of reaction
in terms of the rate constant.
They prefer to use a different
quantity called the half-life.
The half-life is a little more
practical.
It is more directly obvious what it
is related to.
The half-life is basically what you
get if you take this equation here
and plug in c naught over two.
It is the time it takes to consume
half of the reagent that is present.
If I start with c naught and I plug
in c naught over two and solve for
time that is going to give me the
half-life. And if you do that you
will end up with t to the one-half
is equal to the natural log of two,
which is 0.693 over k.
The half-life is inversely
proportional to the rate constant
and mediated by the natural log of
two. And it turns out for this
reaction, the half-life,
t one half for this reaction is 4.
billion years. If you spill this
into the sandbox at the neighborhood
park, it is going to be a while
before you can go back
there and play.
It will take you 4.
billion years just to get the
concentration down to half of what
it is, and then 9 billion years will
get it down to a quarter,
etc. And the nice thing about
half-life, and the only time I would
ever ask you to calculate half-life
is in connection with first-order
reactions. Because only for
first-order reactions is half-life
independent of concentration.
For every other order of reaction
the half-life is a function of
concentration in which case it is a
useless quantity,
except to perhaps professors of
chemistry.
We will not ask you for this except
in the case of first-order.
T one-half independent of
concentration for n equals one.
You can prove to yourself, for
higher order, how the half-life
varies with concentration.
I said that would look at the other,
which is second-order reactions,
and here is an example. It is
dimerization of aluminum trichloride.
Aluminum trichloride can
form the dimer Al2Cl6.
This is gas phase.
And right off the bat I am going to
let c be the concentration of
aluminum trichloride.
And it is second-order because the
rate of disappearance of aluminum
trichloride goes as the square.
Now, this is one of those instances
where it is really tempting because
this reaction has a two in front of
it. And it turns out that the rate
of disappearance of aluminum
trichloride goes as kc squared.
But do not, do not,
I am going to say it three times,
do not assume that this is the rule
that because you saw it once that
this is always the case that the
stoichiometry gives you the order of
reaction. This is not the general
case. It happens in this reaction
for reasons that we will go into
later, but generally you have to
measure the order of reaction.
And so if we go through the same
analysis we will have minus dc over
c squared equals k dt.
We will do the integration.
Eventually, we end up with this
relationship. The reciprocal of
concentration is a linear function
of time. That means the functional
that we need is given here.
The way to determine if something
is second-order or not is to take
this ordinary time line,
concentration versus time,
which is always going to look like
this.
To the naked eye you are going to
say I don't know if that is
first-order or second-order,
but I can detect a straight line.
Instead, if I map this into one
over c versus time,
I should end up with a straight line
starting at one over c naught.
And the slope of that line should
be k. When I see that this is a
straight line,
I go n equals two.
And the slope is the rate constant.
If this were not second-order, I
would not get a straight line.
This allows me to proceed and get
the order of reaction.
And, in fact, what I am showing you
is one of the ways people determine
order of reaction.
They use the integrated form of the
rate equation.
And so this is called the integral
method to determine order of
reaction. Determination
of order of reaction.
The first way is integral method.
And it is essentially a comparison
with the integrated form
of the rate law.
Integrated rate law equation.
This is really inspection. This is
trial and error,
but we don't say trial and error
because we are from MIT so
we use fancier words.
We say by inspection.
That is how you tell a boss you
don't know what you are doing.
We really have to do this by
inspection, sir.
What I do is I try n equals one.
If I get an arbitrary data set, I
try n equals one,
I try n equals two,
and after that I say forget it and I
am going to go to the other method.
Let me show you a couple of slides
that indicate this.
Here is a data set.
I pulled this out of some book.
This is a reaction. This is time.
This is the concentration of some
species. And don't worry about that.
We will get to that in a second.
Here is your data set. This is all
you have. And if you plot these,
here is what they look like. This
is concentration in moles per unit
volume as a function of time.
And there is c naught normalized to
one unit, and it is attenuating.
It is over 500 seconds, we are down
to about 20% of the initial value.
I say what is the order of reaction?
Well, I cannot tell.
What I am going to do is say now
let's take natural log of c versus
time. Bingo, straight line.
On this basis, I conclude that it
is a straight line.
And the slope of this line is the
rate constant.
But just to show you that it
doesn't always work,
I said just for grins and chuckles,
plot that same data set as one over
c. And look what happens.
When I plot it as one over c,
I don't get a straight line, so it
really does discriminate.
It does not give me what I was going
to expect in terms of a straight
line, except when I have the proper
order of reaction.
Now let's see another way that we
can get at this,
and this is called the differential
method. We are not going to use the
integrated form of the rate equation.
We will use the differential form.
And, to compress the notation, I am
going to let lower case r be the
rate. The rate is lower case r
which I am going to let stand
for minus dc by dt.
See how I get my fonts more and more
compressed? I start with the big
square brackets,
then I get to this and now I get to
this. It is getting tighter and
tighter. Now I can write the rate
equation as the rate goes as kc to
the n. There is the arbitrary rate
equation. And now what I am going
to do is take the logarithm of the
equation. I can map that into the
logarithm of the rate.
The log of a product is the sum of
the log, so that will be the
logarithm of the rate constant plus
n times the logarithm of
concentration.
Now what I can do is start with
concentration as a function of time.
We know it starts at some value c
naught and attenuates.
Now I am going to plot the slope,
the rate of consumption, not as a
function of time but as a function
of concentration.
Here is the initial concentration.
This is going to represent the
slope r naught,
which is equal to minus dc by dt at
time t naught when concentration
equals c naught.
I am going to end up with a data
pair r naught and c naught.
And, ultimately, here is what I
want to do.
I might want to make this plot of
log of the rate versus log of the
concentration.
I have my first data pair,
r naught, c naught, and go over here.
And then some arbitrary time later,
here is t naught, here is t1. At t1,
I take the slope,
so this is now slope r1 which is
minus dc by dt at t1.
And now the concentration is equal
to some new value c1.
This was c naught. This is c1.
Now I am taking the data pairs r1,
c1. I take that and they go over
here. Let's do one more because I
am having so much fun.
This is t2 and here is c2.
The concentration has dropped to c2.
I take the slope r2,
blah, blah, blah, c2. And so I take
that and will put it over here.
I am going to end up with a
straight line.
If you don't get a straight line in
a log-log plot you are an idiot.
You are working with chemical
systems. I mean log-log linearizes
everything. What do I have here?
I have a straight line, log r
versus log c. The slope is n,
the order of reaction. And what is
this intercept?
The value of the intercept is log k.
Superb. I did that with the same
data set. What I did is I went back.
Here is the rate.
I took the rates by taking the
delta c over delta t.
I went down the curve,
differentiated. Those are my rates.
And now here is log r versus r c.
Straight line.
And it has a slope of one.
So? In fact, the least squares
gives me 1.018.
It allows for a little bit of
variation in experimental
measurement, and it gives
me a straight line.
This is the differential method for
determining the rate of reaction.
Well, I said we can increase
productivity by increasing
concentration.
We are going to increase
productivity by increasing
temperature. But there is another
way we can increase productivity.
And the way we can do that is by
modifying the value of k.
I am showing you how to do it by
playing with temperature.
There is another way to modify the
value of k, modify the value of
activation energy.
And we do that by the use of a
catalyst. Increase rate via
catalyst. And what the catalyst
does is decreases the activation
energy for reaction.
And, by decreasing the activation
energy, all other things being equal,
same concentration,
same temperature, therefore,
that means it increases k at given
temperature. The way we can view
the catalyst as working is the
following. If I plot this energy
versus extent of reaction.
This is the reactants at some energy
arbitrarily denoted as shown.
And the products have to be at a
lower energy. If the products are
not at a lower energy than the
reactants, there is no driving force
for the reaction in the first place,
but we know we have to go up to some
activated state in order to get up
to the corner of the box,
so to speak. Here we are.
This is the energy state of the
reactants, this is the energy state
of the products,
but we have to invest this amount of
energy in order to allow
for the throughput.
This is activation energy.
What a catalyst does is it reduces
the level of activation needed by
assisting with some kind of a
physical process such as adsorbing
gas molecules so that they can find
each other more readily and react.
This is catalyzed. This is Ea.
And now this one here
is Ea catalyzed.
The catalyst reduces the activation
energy. And the result is,
if we go over to this curve,
n(E) versus E, we still have the
same temperature distribution.
We have not changed that. If this
is the activation energy as stated
for the reaction in the presence of
the catalyst, the catalyst reduces
the activation energy, Ea catalyzed.
Therefore, the area under the curve
is much, much greater under the
influence of catalysis.
And, while we are in the
neighborhood, there are other actors
that can increase the activation
energy. That is up here.
This is Ea under the influence of
an inhibitor. And sometimes we want
inhibitors. What is an inhibitor?
An inhibitor is going to raise the
activation energy.
Now the area under the curve is
even smaller. Inhibited.
For example, a catalyst we want in
order to improve productivity such
as conversion of pollutants in
automotive exhaust.
We want to increase the
productivity. But an inhibitor,
we want to put in to slow down an
undesirable reaction such as to
reduce the rate of corrosion in your
coolant. It flows through the
radiator and engine block.
There are chemicals that are added
to inhibit the corrosion processes
that are undesirable for the
long-term maintenance
of the automobile.
We see how there is a relationship
between the catalysis,
inhibition and the energy available
to drive a reaction.
Let's see what we have up here for
five minutes today.
Radiocarbon dating.
This is from Willard Libby who got
the Nobel Prize in 1960.
In the upper atmosphere,
under the influence of cosmic rays,
neutrons are generated.
And the neutrons react with nitrogen
to form carbon 14.
And we know that carbon 14 is
present in about one part per
trillion. This is now part of the
carbon cycle down here,
all the carbon atoms in all living
things. Because we are constantly
exchanging carbon with our
surroundings, take any carbon atom
out of any one of us and we will
have dominantly carbon 12,
about 1% carbon 13 and one part per
trillion carbon 14.
But when we die,
we stop exchanging with the
surroundings. In fact,
if you were looking for a new
euphemism for death,
instead of saying "he passed away",
you could say "he exited the carbon
cycle." He is no longer playing.
So, upon death, we stop exchanging.
We start at one part per trillion
when we die, and then this reaction
takes place. The carbon 14 decays
radioactivity to nitrogen plus beta.
It is a beta decay.
And so if we measure the ratio of
carbon 14 to carbon 12,
knowing the half-life is 5730 years,
we can figure out how long it has
been since we checked out of the
carbon cycle. These are some things
that have been carbon dated.
There are some things that have
been looked at over time.
One of the assumptions is that the
rate of neutron generation and
carbon 14 generation has not changed
over, let's say,
the last 10,000 to 15,
00 years, which is really a blink of
an eye by cosmic measurements.
Here are some things that have been
dated. The Dead Sea scrolls came in
at about 1,917 years back from today,
but with uncertainty,
plus or minus 200. This is Mount
Mazama that erupted in Oregon and
made Crater Lake.
It quenched some trees.
The charcoal from those trees comes
in at 6453 from today.
The charcoal from the cave painting
in Lascaux in France dates
back 15,516 years.
That is the kind of stuff that you
see. Here is one that is quite
controversial,
and we are not strangers to
controversy. This is the Shroud of
Turin. This is a painting showing
what is to be the burial shroud of
Christ. It shows the two images
that it is supposed to have.
This is how the shroud would have
been. It is a linen piece about 14
feet long. This is from a National
Geographic Article of about six,
seven years ago showing various
features on the shroud.
This is the shroud and this is the
painting, just to give you a sense
of what is supposed to be there.
And so in the mid 80s fragments of
that shroud were sent to three
different laboratories in three
different countries,
and the fabric was dated to come
from this interval of about 1260 to
1390. This shows the cartoon of
cosmic rays generating carbon 14
which goes into flax.
Once we pick the flax and make
linen, it is out of the carbon cycle.
And these are going out like twink
lights. Then you can calculate the
various things.
This is very hotly contested.
Some people are ardent believers.
They believe that the data that
were gathered were false because
there was a fire in 1532.
Here is a painting showing people
repairing the shroud using candles.
And there are arguments that there
is paraffin from the candles that is
coating the outer surface of the
filaments. In fact,
you are analyzing the carbon from
the paraffin that was observed on
the filament. It is all about
sampling. Very interesting.
If you get on the Internet,
you will find all kinds of stuff on
there about it.
There is a question,
how do you do the test?
You know the way to do it properly
is to take the whole thing,
put it in a giant blender so you are
not looking at surface effects.
This is the problem, how to do
nondestructive evaluation of an
artifact. I will see you on Friday.